so you you ended up getting I don't know
whether the term is D platform from
patreon or not but removed from patreon
and you'd mentioned about it happened
with Milo and it happened with some
other of your contemporaries but based
on what I saw the immediate backlash
from some other pretty prominent figures
online lent a lot of publicity and
credence to your side of the story it
certainly seemed quite a few people who
came out in support of you right yeah I
mean the the the problem is that patron
didn't even try to really justify it
they they can't appeal to their own
Terms of Service when doing this that's
the thing that's why people talk about
it as if it's a political maneuver
because it does appear to be a political
maneuver I mean I've been on patreon for
four years and they knew what I was like
when I joined I haven't really changed
you know my political opinions are not
the same but still in the same vein you
know this is I'm not particularly
changed there and I've always been
opposed to political correctness and
their effective effective ly saying
because somewhere else you were
politically incorrect on our platform
we're going to get rid of you even
though our Terms of Service only said
it's things that happen on our platform
and jack conte literally said you know
we don't care about what you do on
twitter we care about you doing patrons
okay well that that seems fairly cut and
dried to me and so when they're just
literally reversing this then I mean how
was I to know
I hope ASSA bleah wasn't have been so
unpolitical e correct
had I known the patron were watching
everything really yeah I mean you need
to be careful what you say when you go
to the toilet now or like what you say
when you're out walking the dog I mean
where does the it is getting quite well
Ian I I really do think and now it's
it's I mean like I never really thought
we'd end up living in some kind of like
omnipotent panopticon where you you can
no no cause like anything you've said at
any point in time or space can now be
found by Internet sleuths if it's on the
internet if it's in social media I mean
look at Genki UGA's old like when he was
in college whatever his old blog from
the 90s the
had up I mean it was really rude you
know it was it was like young men's
brood talk and you know obviously he's
not saying this to women's faces so it's
not like he's going on and saying hey
lady you've got a nice rack you know
blah blah blah blah
he did kind of sound like elliot rodger
while he was doing yeah but that was all
dug up like 20 years later after he'd
disavowed it like ten years previously
yeah and said look it's just something I
did and I'm not proud of it but now it
doesn't matter I'm not God kicked off of
the board of the Justice Democrats a
political organization in the US and him
and Carl kolinsky and so it's just that
it's merciless yeah absolutely missus
and this it's currently happening to
Tulsi Gabbard right now like she was
raised in a right wing Christian
anti-gay household like actively her dad
was an activist against gay rights and
she grew up naturally with a bunch of
those opinions yeah as you expect yeah
and she you know like she was she going
to Congress six years ago but before
then she had already changed her mind on
the idea of gay rights which is why she
joined the Democrats and now she's being
just grilled for it like I'm seeing that
she's such a mild person and I'm just
seeing the worst kind of backlash from
the very far left activists who are now
like well if you were once ever against
gay rights then you know you are forever
and we're just gonna treat you like you
still hold this bigger it's it's such a
awful yeah and it's the the problem is
because everybody wants to have this
absolutist approach to people are either
bad or good and the gray area is too
gray and any seceding of ground is you
allowing them to proliferate these
really terrible ideas but Sam Harris has
a great concept where he talks about a
the son of a terrorist over in Iraq and
he says this sons two years old so let's
imagine the free will that he's got he's
two years old and he's maybe stamping on
insects or something like that and you
think well is it his fault you got one
no no like look at look at the people
he's around he's got this aggression
it's really aggressive culture and blah
blah blah okay roll it forward he's
seven years old he's at school and he's
bullying people y'all is it his fault
now and got one now it's still probably
not his fault he's got this crazy honor
culture
and he's very very highly held within
society okay now continue to roll the
tape forward now he's 15
now he's 20 now he's a warlord at 30
like yeah yeah where do we stop or where
do we draw the line about understanding
people's backgrounds yeah that's a
really really good point and a really
good way of laying out - at what point
do we hold people accountable for the
things they believe and can we allow
them to change if they want to and it
seems like the far left is before they
can vote like I mean if you're not
allowed to vote you basically what we're
saying to you what the government is
saying to you is your views are not
sufficiently well formed for you to be
able to contribute to the national
discourse yeah yeah so and how can
anything from circa that period be used
as a canary in a coal mine for what
you're like is a real person a perfect
example we've had nothing he can we've
got a guy who works for a sir Canadian
dude called if he and I was talking to
the other day and I said I just seen
you've changed you've changed you
Twitter handle why have you done that
and he says man like I've had Twitter
since I was like 11 and some of the [ __ ]
that's on there cuz he's doing law at
the moment he's I just don't want in ten
years time so I'm on it go back and find
the shout was tweeting when I was 12
years old
yeah he's not got dreams of going into
[ __ ] Congress but this is how
pervasive the situation is that people
are terrified of having something
dredged up it's unbelievable this is why
I call it a panopticon because it really
is someone having the ability to see
everything about your life if they just
care to look you know I mean I tell you
what I am so god damn glad the social
media didn't exist when I was a child
saying I am just and I'm gonna keep my
son off of it for as long as I can
because I mean it's awful it's awful the
idea that like because I think that this
is something that's rarely thought about
but like I think that people's pasts are
generally considered to be in in regular
society sort of a part of their private
lives you know if something bad happened
to you in the past or you did something
silly if you've paid the penance for it
so you went to jail
thing you know like three years later
you're going for a job you know it's
appropriate to leave that in the past
because otherwise the person can never
improve and they're never given any
incentive to improve and so I currently
effectively stuck being a criminal
forever and but now the way the internet
works is that no any link can be sent to
you and is as fresh as the day it was
first printed you know first uploaded or
whatever and so it's it's it's all there
and it's gonna be there forever and so
we're gonna have to be really really
careful about what we say in public I
guess it's a very nasty trail of
breadcrumbs back to a person that you
never are the udu no longer are I
suppose about am i right in thinking
that sam Harris has closed his patreon
account now he has yeah so still Pete
Senor Davidson so how many how many
patrons do you think it combined between
them I wouldn't even know it must be a
fair number though fifty thousand
probably maybe something like that
I honestly don't know he's got to be a
lot though yeah a lot and they are now
moving across to they they're actually
setting up their own platform then but I
don't know what it's called yet okay I'm
also gonna be looking forward to using
it but I'm also using subscribe start
which is another platform that was
existing before any of this happened it
you know so I think it opened in May
last year and and speaking to the cartel
nature of Silicon Valley in fact the the
woman who was overseeing the deep
platforming of my patreon accounts had
worked at PayPal for eight years and and
then she was put in charge of patreon
trust and safety team and then the day
or the day after I and a bunch of other
YouTube content creators went to
subscribe star which is there already
content creators on there obviously and
they've been operating quite happily for
six months but we went over there and
suddenly PayPal and all of the other
sort of Silicon Valley processing firms
decided to pull their services from
paper from from subscribe start as if
subscribe star had done something wrong
or as if we were being censored by
Silicon Valley itself or something like
that this is why
I really am certain that it's a cartel
it's so juvenile isn't it it's terrible
yeah I mean if patreon don't want me on
okay but what's that got to do subscribe
so I mean like I still have a PayPal
account
eBay and yeah I haven't made the
platform from PayPal so why when I or a
bunch of us go to another platform the
PayPal pull out of a platform it's like
[ __ ] you still give me money you do
that so why so I can only see it as
being then protecting the patreon from
the competition cuz obviously subscriber
is not based in Silicon Valley yeah so
so is that being reversed now what do
you mean sorry the PayPal not accepting
payments through no I believe subscribe
star have figured out a way to get
around it by using some other processor
probably outside US isn't that bizarre
that bringing across some of the biggest
patreon or the biggest sort of crowd
funded content creators on the Internet
was actually one of the worst things
probably operationally for about 24
hours that could have happened well yeah
I mean the thing is I don't think anyone
really expected PayPal so right we're
not gonna do business with you anymore
because none of the people who patreon a
done business with have been a problem
you know I mean we'd all you know it all
been on patreon for years and patreon
had no problems and suddenly they'll
that's not politically correct enough we
get we've got an excuse to get rid of
you and we're not gonna let you go to
another platform because we're gonna get
paypal to it's very very strange crazy
crazy juvenile
[Music]
you